[Music]
hey guys it's Janna here so you have
been extremely dedicated to your fitness
plan and eating a well balanced diet so
after being so strict for a period of
time it is normal to Crave for that
chocolate cookie dough ice cream
cheesecake or any other naughty food
well the good news is eating your
favorite naughty food or cheat meal
occasionally can help with your weight
loss so what is a cheat meal a cheat
meal is when you consciously allow
yourself to indulge in something you
would normally stay away from on a
regular basis you should consume a
well-balanced and nutritious diet filled
with vegetables fruits whole grain
protein and eat the right amount of
calories for your needs and goals when
you take a pre-planned approach towards
your cheat meal it can actually help to
speed up your weight loss process that's
because cheat meal can reset hormones
responsible for metabolism and Insulin
regulation remage glycogen for increased
energy and keep calorie burning and fat
torching mechanisms High when you know
you can be a little looser with your
diet and treat yourself to those
forbidden Foods you tend to be more
motivated and stay on track with your
goals so here are seven steps to eat
cheat meals and still lose weight the
first step is to know how often you're
going to cheat to Simply put if you have
just started a weight loss program
program or you have just started to
adopt a healthy lifestyle then I would
recommend you to have one cheat meal
once a week this will give your body and
mind a chance to get over the withdrawal
symptoms of processed or unhealthy food
which you may have been eating for many
years and having only one cheat meal a
week will also help to build up focus
and self-control for a long-term success
once you start to embrace a healthier
and fitter lifestyle and as you start
getting leaner the frequen quency of
your cheat meals may actually increase
that's because the lower your body fat
levels are the more your body wants to
hold on to the fat it has and some of
you may actually heat a weight loss
Plateau so in order to drop the last few
pounds you can increase your cheat meals
to twice a week this will keep your body
guessing and to increase your metabolism
to continue burning fat more efficiently
and the Second Step be mindful of your
calories yes even your cheating needs to
be recorded in your food diary this is
the only way to be certain you're not
completely ruining all your effort for
the entire week cheat meal should not be
treated like a buffet it is certainly
not eat as much as you can instead eat
between 500 to 1,000 calories more than
your usual day although cheat meal
allows you to indulge in what you would
normally stay away from you should still
practice focus and self-control in order
to achieve your ultimate fitness goal
the third step is to pre-plan your cheat
maal many people in the fitness or
health industry actually do not like to
use the word cheat they prefer to look
at it as a reward meal for all the hard
work you have put in I'm sure you might
have notice as you try to lose weight
you become somewhat of a social outcast
you might not be able to eat out and
enjoy your meals with your family and
friends as frequently as you used to so
pre-plan your reward or chip meal and
make it as a time where it is socially
beneficial to you no matter how we avoid
it bad food will always be around when
you're out with family or friends I like
to save my cheat meal for the weekend
where I can loosen up and enjoy going
for dinner and not worry having to say
no to every Temptation so make it a time
to reward and celebrate your efforts if
you associate your treats to feeling
guilty you are more likely to lose
control hence letting go if you
associate your treats to to Celebration
you are more in control of your meals
and you will know when to stop when
you're satisfied this then leads on to
my next point which is to build a
positive relationship with food be
honest how many of you have allowed
yourself to indulge in bad food and then
feel extremely guilty afterwards if that
happens on a regular basis it is very
likely that you see food as a threat and
something negative that may sabotage
your fitness plan just know that no
single food causes weight gain weight
management is based on your total
calorie intake so if you practice
moderation self-control and see food as
nourishing both your body and soul all
foods can be part of a healthy diet I
believe that in order to build a
positive relationship with food long
term it has to start from within so
change your mindset and change your food
language instead of saying this food has
a lot of calories it is extremely bad
for me and I feel extremely guilty
change your food language tell yourself
this food has a lot of calories but if I
really want it I'm going to indulge in
moderation as you change your food
language you will also naturally have a
more positive relationship with food
which will help with a healthy weight
management long term step number five is
to enjoy with all your senses the
difference between binging and enjoying
a cheat meal is that you know you're in
control your fully aware and you're
fully present with your meal you're able
to eat until you're satisfied not until
you're stuffed so put effort into your
cheat meals when you indulge serve it on
a pretty plate so that it is appealing
to your sight taste your food smell your
food eat in small bites so that you can
fully appreciate the texture and taste
do not eat in front of any distraction
such as your computer TV or do any other
activities just by taking time to
indulge in your meals and eat in small
bites you will have a much more
satisfying and mindful meal experience
without overeating and step number six
is to learn to compromise a cheat meal
should always be within control this
means learning to give and take it is
not a license to binge so if you happen
to be a dessert lover just like me then
go light on your main cost skip the
starter drinks and CH a healthier lower
calorie main cost so that you can
splurge on desserts if you already know
what you plan to order prior to visiting
a restaurant you are more likely to
stick to your portion and enjoy a
satisfying cheat meal and the final step
is to be kind to yourself no matter how
much we plan or have strong self-control
it is impossible to be perfect
throughout your weight loss Journey
sometimes you may overindulge in your
cheat meal or you may have more cheat
meals in a week than what you intended
everybody sleeps up and it is absolutely
fine as long as you do not allowed one
sleep turn into a relapse don't let that
be an excuse for you to get back into
your old eating patterns instead when
you sleep up take notes learn from it so
that you can anticipate and take
self-control in the future to sum up
rewarding and recognizing your effort by
having cheat meals have been proven to
increase motivation and contribute to a
higher success weight loss rate that is
because cheat meal feeds the soul and
feeding the soul keeps your body and
mind at ease and when you're in balance
with yourself you are more likely to
stay focused and achieve your ultimate
goal all the best for new fitness food
and motivational videos please like
share and subscribe to my YouTube
channel and website do follow me on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter to stay
connected with me thanks
[Music]
guys